qué tan preocupante es el panorama
general de los derechos humanos a nivel
mundial y cuáles son las tendencias más
peligrosas
buenas tardes valentina muchas gracias
por la invitación y realmente la
tendencia es de un aumento de la
autocracia que nos preocupa enormemente
y el informe lo que hace es resaltar la
situación de derechos humanos en 100
países donde vemos en muchos de ellos
este patrón pero a pesar de este aumento
de la autocracia vemos también que a la
gente salido a la calle para defender
los principios democráticos y que vamos
a avanzar en frenar este aumento de la
autocracia a nivel global en la medida
que quienes son líderes democráticos en
el mundo hagan un mejor trabajo
defendiendo la democracia y dejen de
mirar a veces priorizando los intereses
internos cuáles son los casos más graves
en américa latina' para que hablen de un
retroceso de décadas
en américa latina estamos enormemente
preocupados no sólo por las dictaduras
puras y duras como lo son nicaragua cuba
venezuela sino porque hay varios casos
de líderes que fueron electos
democráticamente y que una vez en el
poder hacen caso omiso a las garantías
más elementales de la democracia y se
dedican a ir en contra de la
independencia judicial de la prensa
independiente de el trabajo de la
sociedad civil los casos más extremos
posiblemente sean el presidente
bolsonaro en brasil el presidente de
lópez obrador en mexico el presidente
bucl en el salvador
y hay varios casos más de países donde
los gobiernos han socavado la
independencia judicial o en casos más
extremos como en bolivia por ejemplo
usado el sistema de justicia en contra
de sus opositores políticos la pandemia
puede ser considerado un factor decisivo
para que se hayan cometido violaciones a
los derechos humanos como las que
ustedes denuncian
la pandemia tuvo dos grandes
consecuencias en materia de derechos
humanos una tiene que ver con haberse
transformado en una excusa para que
líderes autoritarios
apliquen medidas de restricción de
derechos que posiblemente hubieran
querido adoptar sin la pandemia
restringiendo la libertad de movimiento
la posibilidad de manifestarse la
publicación de información pero además
ha dejado un saldo grave en materia
social y económica
intensificando la desigualdad y hay
altos niveles de pobreza el acceso a la
educación de los niños y niñas se ha
visto gravemente afectado en el contexto
de la pandemia y esto nos deja un saldo
muy complicado que además ha contribuido
en muchos países a la migración que es
otro de los grandes problemas en américa
latina' hoy tanto de venezolanos como
nicaragüenses como centroamericanos
están hoy trasladándose y enfrentando
enormes desafíos y en muchos casos
abusos durante sus trayectos